israeli airstrikes have killed at least
10 people in the gaza strip including a
senior palestinian militant and a
five-year-old girl that triggered a
barrage of rockets fired back at israel
from gaza the israeli government says it
targeted the islamic jihad militant
group for what it called an imminent
threat
israeli forces target an apartment
building in gaza city just one of many
airstrikes launched into the coastal
strip
israel says the attacks were in response
to an imminent threat from the
palestinian-islamic jihad group
the strikes come after israeli forces
arrested a senior militant in the west
bank early this week
israel carried out a precise
counter-terror operation against an
immediate threat
our fight is not with the people of gaza
islamic jihad is an iranian proxy that
wants to destroy the state of israel and
kill innocent israelis the head of
islamic jihad is in in tehran as we
speak
we will do whatever it takes
to defend our people
an islamic jihad commander was killed in
the strikes and the group vowed to
retaliate
this is a declaration of all-out war
against the palestinian people we will
respond to that this is a violation and
disregard for all the efforts that have
been made over the past days in order to
restore calm we dealt positively with
these efforts but the enemy was as usual
treacherous and carried out this raid
and now we clearly say that we will
respond to this crime with all our might
as a five-year-old girl is mourned fears
of an escalation are rising
israeli jets continue to pound targets
in gaza while palestinian militants have
been firing rockets back into southern
israel
vermonters let's bring in our dw
correspondent tanya kramer in jerusalem
hello tanya now this is the territory's
worst escalation of violence since a war
last year and it's worsening do people
fear another war
well absolutely i think people are
deeply worried about this especially in
gaza you mentioned it they hardly
recovered there from the last war in two
in may 2021
now of course we don't know yet they're
in the middle of an escalation right now
whether this will take days or whether
this will be a full blown war at the end
but it has been certainly a very
difficult night for people in the south
of israel but also of course in the gaza
strip the israeli military house
continued to carry out airstrikes they
they said that they have targeted at
least 30 sites it describes belonging to
the
palestinian militant group islamic jihad
at the same time
rockets have been launched all morning
there have been air raid sirens so
people in the south have to stay in
their safe rooms in their
bomb shelters now the israeli army says
that over 190 rockets were fired since
uh yesterday
mainly in the south some in the center
with the iron dome the defense system um
intercepting
many of them some also fell in open
areas and some also fell inside gaza
that is according to the israeli army
so
what is being done to calm tensions
between the two sides
well eventually um you know this has to
come to an end but again this has just
started
and the question is when and what is
actually the outcome because gaza has
seen many of such military escalations
and
four wars in the past a decade
or so so we heard some reactions already
by the international community the u.n
special envoy for the middle east peace
process has called for calm also saying
you know it's the civilians uh in the
areas that are suffering uh the most
from it there have been uh efforts
usually in the past and also last week
leading up to this escalation by egypt
that's traditionally
the mediator between militant groups in
gaza
in this case after the arrest of an
islamic jihad leader in the west bank
and
israel but to no avail and we saw the
attack yesterday then by israel
on gaza leading now to this escalation
so at the moment it's unclear you know
where this is going and it's very
difficult of course
for people living there
dw correspondent tanya kramer in
jerusalem thank you
you